Oh Xbox one what a rocky six years it's
been but along the way it's become its
truest bestest self and now with a new
console on the way with a sort of newish
name we take a look back at the 37 most
memorable moments of the Xbox one's
journey from 0 to 1 to X yeah
you can watch TV on your Xbox one you
can watch movies on your Xbox one you
can watch TV on your Xbox one you can
Skype with your buds on Xbox one you can
watch TV on your Xbox one watching TV TV
TV TV on Xbox will immerse you you
couldn't play use games on Xbox one
this is how you share your games on ps4
thanks you can play use games on Xbox
one you always have to be online with
Xbox one you don't always need to be
online with Xbox one the console is 499
dollars with Kinect required the console
is $399 with no Kinect requirement Don
Mattrick fortunately we have a product
for people who aren't able to get some
form of connectivity it's called Xbox
360 right Phil Spencer or as I like to
say Xbox Daddy X hmm backwards
compatible with 360 games backwards
compatible with the original Xbox games
Xbox game pass how great Xbox game pass
is did I mention Xbox game pass
it's good ID at Xbox giving a platform
to independent developers
after years of III teases crackdown 3
came out but sadly scalebound got camp
the slimmer Xbox one asked with HDR
support and 4k blu-ray player the
beefier Xbox one X that plays games in
4k the all-digital Xbox one said
addition the elite controller for pro
players the elite controller series 2
for pro ur players the adaptive
controller for all players cross played
with Nintendo cross play with Sony
acquiring minecraft but letting it be on
other consoles helping to create Ori and
cuphead and then releasing it on other
consoles thanks Xbox more halo more
gears more Forza sunset overdrive and
then that game that remedy made before
control but with the that freeze that
mr. freeze guy from x-men yeah that one
studio acquisitions lots and lots of
studio acquisitions
what were your most memorable moments
from the Xbox one let us know in the
comments below and with that any
predictions you have an Xbox series X
maybe things they'll wash with and take
away or things that they'll add
anything's possible
anyways thank you so much for watching
Xbox off
[Music]